I also wanted to welcome you to Twitter  you just you just joined Twitter yeah I  just joined Twitter yeah how's it going  well it's pretty fun but I want it I was  wondering if I could you know do a tweet  with you sure yeah yeah I mean like a  what like say something or like a photo  let's let's do a photo okay okay all  right all right now that you can would  tweet out yeah what can we do because I  want to be tweeted on your Twitter that  means nothing I don't know what do you  want to do something different yoga yoga  pose would be great yeah can you show us  a cool yoga pose can you do that yeah  address yeah okay all right okay why  don't you show us a yoga pose and we'll  figure out something to do Andy can you  take a I was told to grab the camera  ready  okay oh my god okay  [Applause]  that was fantastic  Jen Copeland's here stick around  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]